- MAN, SCREW THOSE GUYS.
I DON'T BURN THINGS
BECAUSE MY TEAMS
WIN CHAMPIONSHIPS.
I DO IT
FOR THE INSURANCE MONEY.
- OH, MY GOD.
A REAL BLACK MAN.
[gasps]
I HOPE IT'S NOT TOO MUCH
TO ASK,
BUT I'D CONSIDER IT AN HONOR
IF YOU'D BITCH SLAP ME
AS HARD AS YOU CAN.
- WHAT?
GET YO ASS OUT OF HERE.
- DENZEL, THAT'S RUDE.
[slaps]
- [groans]
- "BITCH SLAP."
THAT'S OFFENSIVE.
I SHOULD SLAP THAT BITCH.
STEVE, YOU HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT'S IT LIKE
TO BE THE ONLY BLACK PERSON
FOR MILES AROUND.
EVERYONE STARING AT ME,
LIKE I'M A CRIMINAL!
[people murmuring]
- WHAT? I DON'T SEE
WHAT YOU'RE SO MAD AT.
SO PEOPLE ENJOY LOOKING
AT YOU.
YOU'RE, LIKE, A--
- LIKE A MONKEY IN THE ZOO?
- EXACTLY, YOU'RE LIKE
A MONKEY IN THE ZOO.
PERFECT ANALOGY.
- DO YOU KNOW
HOW RACIST THAT IS?
- RACIST? COME ON.
WE BOTH KNOW
THERE'S NO RACISM ANYMORE.
IT ENDED THE DAY
MARTIN LUTHER KING
LANDED ON THE MOON.
- MAN, YOU DON'T KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
- I WOULD LOVE TO BE BLACK
IN TODAY'S SOCIETY.
YOU SET ALL THE TRENDS,
AND YOU GET TO SAY
THE "N" WORD.
YOU HAVE NO IDEA
HOW MANY TIMES
I'VE WANTED TO SAY
THE "N" WORD.
- YOU KNOW WHAT, STEVE?
I NEED SOME TIME AWAY
FROM YOUR DUMB ASS.
- WAIT. YOU'RE NOT MAD AT ME,
ARE YOU?
- OH, NO.
I'M NOT MAD.
[engine revs]
- OKAY, NOW YOU'RE SENDING
MIXED SIGNALS.
[slap]